attention la première et là c'est parti
premier toc toc toc toc toc alors
normalement dit 'ok toi quand même temps
qu'on tape la narine tusa marie ex mari
do marilù marini loops marie lou qui a
été décalé
c'est comme appât
un vote est le cem alors delphine ce
très bon mais c'était au web marilù
marini
saleh a les héros fait le week-end
[Musique]
bravo est la même le cadreur n'est pas
bien à ça et même le cadreur et en
difficulté et rites il n'est pas bien
elle a mis tout le monde
on dit que la musique des années 2000
des stress la halle à stresser tout bon
gras savoye delphine oui ça va très bien
je suis content d'être là bas moi aussi
si vous avez fait toute la semaine cette
série oui oui merci en tout cas si bas
si vous voulez venir demain vous êtes
surveillés je suis là demain aussi
non mais j'ai rentré gagnent parce que
sinon on va plus me reconnaître je vais
rentrer chez moi mon chéri la plus
marquée mais si vous êtes toujours
lembras d'ailleurs roger qui doit nous
regarder ça l'humour roger damour
allez c'est parti deuxième facteur toc
on y va toc toc qui est la nahia mayaki
c'est le web et ses séquelles et merci
mais c'est là bas depuis 30 ans au
pouvoir
merci au maximus d'amour merci d'être là
toujours de bonne humeur maximin d'onet
on a les attentions prochain tac toc toc
toc qui est là et mais c'est qui est
aimée qui n'est pas oui mes pensées
excusez-moi de petites minutes de jeu
je gère un problème ce que vous avez
compris le principe du toc toc toc syrie
toc toc toc
la limite est minorée pas m mais vous
n'avez pas moi là bas c'est sympa à lui
pas de vote sanction ne va pas c'est pas
moi qui les ai tous eus ces geôles
déguisements et mais sinon le reste ça
ne va pas du tout non non je vous le dis
mais soupe et gestes barrières merci
mais non mais oui mon général à foot
très négative vous allez prendre une
tarte dans la gueule
vous aimez bien le privé là j'adore et
je voudrais dire bravo pour les faux
sang une poêle et vous n'aurez pas et
vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de penser
[Musique]
je l'attends attendre y aller c'est
mentir aux attaques tu as gagné très bon
amusement ce soir autant sur l'ascension
et son talent sont pas si mal
allez c'est parti dans un taxi et la
cden qui s'adonnent d'haïti
ma parole
mais vous savez que ça nous va il perd
bien sûr la tête d'un chat errant non
sans lui et ça lui va bien
errant nicolas pernikoff c'est pas mal
du tout as-tu rester comme ça hilale moi
donc c'est dan meehan moi ton coeur
c'est la meilleure
jean corvée mais donne moi ton bon vieux
fantômes bêtasse au bébé chante avec moi
je veux une femme like you a dormi
attention prochain toc toc toc c'est
parti aïe merde
bon c'est que c'est isabelle là on
accomplit donc toc toc toc qui est là
c'est nasser nasser quoi nationale
[Musique]
mais nous y sommes allés très loin ouais
ça naufrage c'est un naufrage
c'est le titanic mais propose est
habillé comme edith piaf quel rapport il
adore rigoler
[Musique]
elle est bâtie ticket jamais votre cas
vous êtes très mal et puis l'avantagent
section fait la famille addams à celle
d'après regardez regardez ses jambes
magnifiques qu'elle ait aller
franchement maniement et bravo ma chérie
bravo qu'elle s'installe et vous ma
chérie d'amour et et vous savez que
j'aime beaucoup comme salif voulons
c'est ce que jamais avant by match me
donnant vous savez quand j'étais une
femme et je me demande si on doit pas
repartir sur ça on va se poser des
questions tous les deux à l'espoir qui
provoque toc toc toc toc qui est là
c'est pippa alors c'est une nouvelle
c'est une nouvelle
eh oui pippa qui alors attendez attendez
la nouvelle on va attendre la nouvelle
on la fera la fin alors on fait un autre
bond en voyage au malawi ont fait la
nouvelle alors oui bien sûr elles à la
fin de crise attention allez c'est parti
et s'est trouvée qui la nouvelle qui va
être auto gars table ce soir à tokyo
prostate au top c'est parti
toc toc toc qui est là c'est inès il est
ce qui in est ce que tu montant et il
est ce que tu me semble
[Musique]
5 g koné jeep à 5,10 et pas 5 des
méchants tout cas y avait sa grand-mère
à l'euro près mais aime et on ne peut
plus chez nous avec une chute bête et et
d'asie tellement la tragédie su ce que
tu préfères
allez merci à l'est bernard montiel
voilà naufrage en direct une fois de
plus sa vie est un naufrage et on est
heureux de l'avoir avec nous sommes à
montbernard oui très bien ça m'a pas mal
mais lemieux pernikoff je trouve ça lui
va à merveille
c'est le film franchement il est oui et
ça lui va sas à jamais inscrite comme ça
ça va faire ça voyez pas que j'allais
déconner qui tape contre le micro ou
fait date et les depuis 200 ans
et c'est pas possible ça n'a rien appris
depuis 20 ans
la demo cloud collier il est déjà
complètement où fut aller le prochain à
des parties alors là elle a deux à ses
tics et là c'est rooney et cécilia rené
cécilia qui oui
c
rien
[Musique]
mais
oh
c'est moi pas mal vous m'emmerdez
pourquoi vous chantez je ne sais pas
chanter pad mais oui alors vox insiste
damien sargue ah oui c'est bien ça la
changera d'avis dans la pierre et vous
mais vous savez que tout va vous un peu
que vous vous êtes limitant à 100 et on
dirait une vraie personne et non mais
sans déconner en garde les personnes et
mes limites au moins son talent et vous
avions pas il ya une petite poubelle
aujourd'hui sachez qu'aujourd'hui on a
fait absent kelly mais novelli on avait
absente
valerie vili on a des absents qui
doteront nommé gel contient des voiliers
hattab son il viendra pas aujourd'hui et
on a décidé d'inviter une jeune fille
quittera la table ce soir qu'on aime
bien ces partis politiques toc toc toc
toc qui est là c'est pippa mais pâques
et finit pas c'est quand j'ai d'ailleurs
que chargé le valide
allez-vous marjolaine qui avait cloué
match et sa première femme à 6 heures de
mer ça va ça passe
moi je m'appelle au fida collagène
aubaine je suis fou de cette chanson
c'est à moi aussi j'adore merci marc
joanny